ça fait des années qu'on sait pas tous
retrouvés
pour fêter noël vous êtes tout pour moi
je veux rattraper le temps perdu
[Musique]
les autorités se demandent si le
justicier masqué qui a terrorisé la
pègre ne serait pas de retour
ont passé refait surface
qui nous au moins six mois et du conte
ses trois fois rien je serais rentré
pour noël je te le promets
[Musique]
je me suis fait beaucoup d'ennemis avait
beaucoup je portais ce costume
vous êtes hockey y est t'es qui toi pour
certaines personnes
[Musique]
le meilleur archer du monde
c'est aussi ce que tu penses
tu as lu chérie je devrais être de
retour d'ici un jour ou deux c'est pas
dieu
aubin
les choses se sont passées
légèrement compliqué ça
[Musique]
ouais
trop dangereux
sûrement pas celle là ne parlait pas
comme si j'avais 5 ans oh la vache
vous savez encore plus balèze que ça
sérieux
[Musique]
tu parles d'un joyeux noël
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]